I told you not to tell anyone you did
not make that clear what are you up to
these days
Tori Vega after graduating from
Hollywood Arts High School what did you
go on to do we really miss all the
shenanigans you got up to on Victorious
we miss watching you and Andre get into
all sorts of trouble we wonder what
happened to back in Jade are they still
together we never get tired or free
watching the show but there are some
huge plot holes we missed the first time
around
Nickelodeon's Victorious was one amazing
show but in his fourth season run there
are a lot of plot holes mistakes and
inconsistencies keep watching for the
most shocking plot holes from the hit
series
Rex is bighead Oh Rex Rex was one of our
favorite characters from Victorious and
he wasn't exactly human okay he wasn't
human at all Rex was a puppet Robbie
Shapiro was such an awkward character in
a lot of ways and his artistic talent
that landed him a spot of Hollywood Arts
High School was ventriloquism Popat
Bastyr and Rex was his prophet it was
pretty hilarious the way Ronnie treated
Rex like a real person
it was even better when all the other
characters treated him like he was a
part of the gang but there's a big
problem with Rex in the pilot episode
Rex has a huge head but in later
episodes his head is a lot smaller what
happened is the Rex we've come to know
and love actually Rex 2.0 is it the same
puppet with a new head
maybe the show's creators just hoped we
wouldn't notice we have to wonder what
happened to the original Rex we aren't
sure why they felt the need to change
him and we definitely want an
explanation Drake and Josh
sometimes shows exists within the same
universe and this is very common on
Disney Channel and Nickelodeon shows
characters will crossover with other
series victorious was created by the
same guy who invented Drake and Josh
Dan Schneider created what a lot of fans
call Schneider vs. but here's the thing
it's not exactly clear how Drake and
Josh
exists in the victorious universe there
were several times that they discussed
Drake and Josh as if it is a TV show
happened on a TV show that would mean
victorious takes place in our world but
then there's Helen Helen takes over as
principal of Hollywood Arts High School
and she is playing the exact same
character as she does on Drake and Josh
what does this mean
is it an inconsistency between episodes
maybe Drake and Josh is supposed to be a
reality show in the victorious universe
that would be super cool
can you imagine Drake and Josh as
reality stars or maybe Dan Schneider
wants us to be confused we just don't
know what to think but this pothole has
a scratching our heads Tory gets stuck
Tory gets stuck was one of the wildest
episodes of Victorious Ravi is
hospitalized because a toy car is stuck
in his intestines
Jane has gone to extreme lengths to keep
Tory from being in the play including
reading Tory's medical file
Tory agrees to have surgery and donate
blood to Ravi that's a huge pothole in
itself it's not exactly clear why Tory
needs to have a whole surgery just to
donate blood and why doesn't the
hospital have Robbie's blood type in
reserve they say it's rare but its own
egative which isn't the most common
blood type in this episode
Tory also gets stuck at no zoo she and
Robbie need to cough up 22 dollars
before they can leave she tweets that
she is using the restaurants computer
but why doesn't she use the computer or
the restaurants phone to contact someone
she can ask them to bring her the money
that seems like an easy fix to us this
episode left us with so many questions
also Jade basically tried to poison Tory
by sending her flowers she's allergic to
that is pretty extreme the other classes
Tory and the rest of the gang attend
Hollywood Arts High School it's a
special arts high school for talented
teenagers they have all sorts of
programs for artistic teenagers there's
music drama dancing and ventriloquism
pourtant part of the high school that's
missing you might not have even noticed
it we certainly missed it the first time
around but if you go back and re-watch
the series pay attention to their
classes they only ever seem to go to art
classes they even take multiple acting
classes and other creative courses but
this is still a high school why aren't
they taking math where are their English
and history classes there are plenty of
real art schools in the United States
students still take normal classes like
algebra and government does it seem odd
that they never study anything normal
that can't be a great way to prepare
them for the real world
also we would have loved to see them in
regular classes
can you imagine Rex and Robbie taking
literature what about cat trying to
learn calculus it would have been so
funny Tori's Locker one of the biggest
mistakes in Victorious happened in
season 1 and honestly we aren't sure how
the set designers and directors missed
it in the great ping-pong scam Tori
learns that there is a ping-pong team
and she quickly finds out that they
aren't a real team but a flashback shows
that two years before Andre back cat
Jade and Robbie finds a ping-pong table
they really want to go to a fancy dinner
at an expensive restaurant called
maestro's so they devised a plan to form
a team to get the $1,500 the school
gives to the sports teams Sikka wits
agrees to sponsor them when they tell
them that the principal could get fired
if they don't get a big trophy then they
go to dinner at maestro's to buy a
trophy it's completely ridiculous and
hilarious and here's the thing in the
flashback we can see Tori's signature
make it shine on her locker in the
background but this supposedly happened
two years before she got there how is
her locker there
hey victorious fans do you love watching
videos about all your favorite TV shows
then you'll love the things click that
big red subscribe button and turn on
notifications to never miss another
video if you're watching on your phone
make sure your notifications are turned
on for YouTube terrible teacher
that last blooper leads us to our next
plot hole Oh sicko it's he was such a
strange character he does a lot of weird
things like climbing in the window to
his classroom and drinking from a
coconut I'm gonna drink its milk the
students like him but he's honestly a
terrible teacher and that's the bottle
how did such a prestigious school like
Hollywood arts allow such a terrible
teacher to work there his lessons are
total nonsense he teaches them things
like improv is like a fine cheese but
not really he always wants to be the
center of attention he helped the
students scam the school out of $1500
feel out Jada pour coffee on Tori in
class he throws a ball at his students
to get their attention that's
behavior should make a teacher lose
their license it really makes no sense
that this guy is an authority figure are
you loving these plot holes and mistakes
keep watching to find out which
Victoria's photo left us dazed and
confused
Trina's admission poor Trina she really
gets a lot of flack over the course of
the show she gets made fun of a lot and
some of it is really mean remember the
time Jayde posted a video of Trina
getting hurt online so everyone would
laugh we know Trina can be really
spoiled and annoying but her character
goes through a lot the whole premise for
Tori getting into Hollywood arts is that
she takes Trina's place in the singing
showcase Trina can't sing at all her
lack of talent is always gossip devout
and made fun of but somehow she still
manages to get into Hollywood arts
okay we know mr. shikou wits isn't quite
in his right mind during her audition
but at some point pretty soon after the
school would figure out that she's not
artistically inclined she might have
some other talents but the show doesn't
address them it just focuses on how
untalented she is it's fine that she
doesn't have
artsy skills but she certainly doesn't
belong at an art school prom problem we
understand that sometimes TV
inconsistencies happen from episode to
episode it's hard to keep up with
everything that characters say
especially when there are a lot of
episodes this sort of thing happens a
lot on Victorious one in particular
happens in season two
Tori convinces the others to have a prom
and through the whole episode the
students swear they've never had a prom
at Hollywood Arts and they don't really
want a normal prom dance but when we
went back and re-watch the pilot episode
we noticed something weird sicko its
tells Kat to tell the others to come
back to the classroom she runs out and
tells Andre Robby and the rest of the
crew what sick' was once Rex responds if
they never had a prom how does that make
any sense
maybe Rex was just being mean even if it
wasn't true but it's definitely a
strange thing to joke about what
happened to Kat one time victorious made
something major happen to a character
and then they never resolved the
storyline in Rex ties the main storyline
was about Rex getting sucked into the
turbo jet Tori convinces a doctor at the
hospital to treat Rex even though he's
just a puppet then she turns the heart
monitor back
after the puppet flatlines but while
they were at the hospital something
happens to cap she goes to talk to the
receptionist after Jay tells her to but
cats a little weird and the receptionist
thinks she belongs to the psychiatric
ward the doctor even says that they
should call in a specialist after cat
scratches her nose with her feet but the
episode just ends with cat locked away
in a padded room none of her friends go
to find her and the episode never
explains what happens they just left her
there it would have been nice and
probably hilarious to see cats storyline
get resolved the smooch this final plot
hole actually happened years after
victorious ended even Jogia who plays
back transparent likes to post throwback
pictures on his social media fans of
Victorious loved these reminders from
the show but in 2017 he posted something
weird it's a picture where back is
laying on Jade's lap and Tory is about
to give him a smooch this photo looks
super intimate but fans cannot figure
out where this photo is from Jade would
never have just sat there while Tory
made a move on back
and we also have no memory of this
happening there is a clip of a similar
scene in the opening credits but Tory
definitely isn't close to beckon it was
this picture photoshopped
if so someone did a great job but why
would even post it on his Instagram
maybe this is something that happens
behind the scenes but that doesn't
explain why it happened it could be a
scene that was cut from the final
version like a dream sequence
either way this weird photo definitely
made Tory and Beck shippers happy that's
a wrap
what was your favorite victorious moment
let us know in the comments section
thanks for watching don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up see you next
time
[Music]
you